jerk
yes Neil what's happening it's that time
again it is that time at that time for
explaining it's that do some splainin to
get some splainin photo anything but
eating you lately so here's the thing
had a little conversation somebody said
to me as surely as the Sun rises in the
east and sets in the west as if to
punctuate their point and I said well
how sewer are you okay since that's the
qualifier house that's the qualify if
that is the fact right that is supposed
to give credence to some other thing
they're telling you right that's your
eye this matters it does matter
okay so this this idea that the Sun rise
in the east and I don't know where it
came from
it's like broadly true but it's it's so
not true
most of the time oh that I'm that I'm
surprised
it has persisted to this day wow that's
a big statement it's so not true most of
the time right that it shouldn't be
considered you know an axiom or be
considered like a verbal Canon right
that's not hanok yeah it's a canon of
communication no which in my opinion I
don't think it should be so it turns out
there is one place on earth where the
Sun always rises exactly due east and
sets exactly due west one place well one
one one one zone on earth's equator if
you live there mm-hmm
the Sun will always rise due east and
set due west every day of the year
gotcha if you live anywhere north or
south of that all the way up to and down
to the Arctic and Antarctic circles
right Yuma you might remember those from
high school geography what elementary
school geography yeah I didn't I didn't
go
school that good where that was
elementary school doubt that might have
been College of me okay it's a college
so if you go up to the Arctic Circle
right as you move away from the equator
the Sun depending on what time of the
year will rise farther and farther away
from due east and set farther and
farther away from due west and what
happens when you hit these are that's
the Arctic Circle and the the Antarctic
Circle which by the way are sixty six
and a half degrees north sixty six and a
half degrees south if you hit those
circles and you step across them there
are days of the year when the Sun
doesn't rise at all because it never set
right and their days the Sun never sets
because it never rose with that the
opposite of what I just said yes the Sun
never Rises because it never sat and the
Sun never sets I never ever rose you
didn't know right so they're they're
they're days of the year where you have
24 hours of darkness
and 24 hours of light so the Sun
basically when it's all like 24 hours
the Sun just moves its way along the
horizon to come right on back the other
side right so we're where's east it's
just oh that's so cool I'm saying it so
anyway whoever came up with the
statement the Sun rises in the east and
sets in the west did not live in the
Arctic that's the theory that's like the
emu it's the Inuits did not come up with
that saying right and the Antarctic
penguins would have never said this no
exactly right exactly yeah it's like in
Star Wars that there's one planet and
it's in a binary star system and so they
they just see you just see both sons all
the time like you never forget to plan
edition okay it's it's not like that at
all but I enjoy the reference why is it
not like that at all okay
we don't know whether that planet is
tipped on its accent all this is
happening because earth is tipped on its
axis right if we were not tipped on our
axis then the Sun would rise due east
and set due west for everybody every day
every time all the time tipped right so
that little 23 degrees actually keeps
the Sun at a place where it looks like
it's coming up and down but really it's
the fact that we're tilted well it will
come up and down it's just not gonna
happen duties no reason to west right
that's all that's all I'm saying that
that's all I'm saying and so so the way
it works is the sun's rising point
actually migrates across the horizon
right and it spends half the year this
is for most of the world's population
who lives between like 20 degrees north
and in 50 degrees north that's most of
the world's population lives in that
those bands it's north and south by the
way so all the the big cities of
Australia and South America they're all
between like 25 and 50 degrees south
latitude and all the big cities in the
north or around there in the north
latitude so here's how it goes so the
Sun will spend half its time rising
south of due east and each day it'll
migrate to a different point so the next
day it'll rise a little closer to do
east and the next day a little closer
and then one day it's gonna rise to east
one day one day one day okay what what
day is that that's the first day of
spring right okay then it keeps
migrating north and the day after spring
and right little north it's not too East
anymore and then it keeps rising farther
and farther and farther north by the way
the arc that the Sun takes I might as
well throw this in here since we're on
the subject is huge when it rises north
of due east because it's on an angle and
that angle goes way across the sky and
high so the Sun is in the sky for many
many hours more than half the hours of
the day the Sun is up first day of
summer right not that
ago not that long ago on that day the
Sun rose as far north as it ever will on
the calendar right and that arc through
the sky goes high and it will set as far
north of Wes as it ever will on the
calendar so you got this arc through the
sky now watch this so that arc after the
first day of summer starts working its
way back and guess what day it crosses
due east and west again just take a
guess at I think equinox which equinox
am I talking about then it's on its way
back right so wait what which one is
vernal the other one so when it's a is
called the September equinox right right
otherwise the autumnal equinox if I'm
trying to be globally inclusive I'll
just say the September equinox because
it's not autumn in the southern
hemisphere their seasons are reversed
for all these same reasons so the Sun
sets it will rise due east set to west
on September 21st there abouts and keeps
going so watch what happens it keeps
growing farther for themselves but it's
angle it's now lower and lower in the
sky and so it's not up for very long oh
my gosh okay and then he gets really
really low in the ancients were freaking
out hey the elections one day the Sun is
gonna be such a let's go disappear the
earth has eaten the Sun except the
horizon has eaten the Sun right so so
when is the lowest arc that's the winter
solstice
all right the winter solstice December
21st right now if you are the ancient
people and you worship the Sun and you
want to make sure it doesn't keep going
you sort of chant and pray and you do
whatever you do to make sure the Sun
doesn't keep dipping down below the
horizon but what you notice is that the
sun's movement the arc of the Sun each
day slows down and it stops it doesn't
keep getting lower
Sun stops not literally in the sky the
arc of the Sun stops getting lower and
then starts back up again
what is Latin for Sun I'm gonna say Sol
Sol sounds got some soul so what is
Latin for stop I'm gonna say cut it out
son stop solstice solstice that and
remember the armistice you're not 130
years old don't remember it so or nah
man that is amazing solstice yeah Don
Cornelius and I just wanna let you know
man this was a stone gasps join us next
time on the Solstice okay for everyone
older than 60 that one come on man
everybody knows Soul Train is still on
TV
Chuck is good to period jokes hey man
look at this afro I am wearing come that
is that you know people been talking
about your hair look at for a long way
don't they say about your hair like that
you don't they say no they say it looks
like a Lego piece that attached to your
head cuz it's so sure yeah so sorry but
see my hair line is all raggedy and gray
and stuff and don't ever show us your
closet other Lego attachments to have
always been so or saying was that the
Solstice once you realize okay so I'm
not good enough just to start because
our props depend on you so what do you
want it to do what are you trying to get
the son to do you don't want to just
stop there no you wanted to go back up
and be victorious it takes a few days to
realize that the Sun has stopped and now
it's on its way back and this became the
foundation of many many celebrations
right around the world Saturnalia
Saturnalia among them
and when the uncertain date the
uncertain day of the year for the birth
of Jesus was going to be put onto the
calendar the Christians said Catholic
Church said let's put Christmas when
people already celebrating that way
it'll be an easy conversion for them
it'll help them okay we don't go out
we'll coop they're all there celebration
and that's why December that's why
Christmas is that in that time of year
December was what exactly um so the
solstice also occurs with the north of
course because they're two solstices in
a year the Sun doesn't keep going north
it goes very far north we have very long
days and then it comes out so so there
you have it and by the way it's and the
farther away you are from the equator
the wider is the range of places over
which the Sun rises and sets okay it's
huge it's just huge that's so cool yeah
and so whoever says sunrise nice and
sets in the west as surely as the Sun
rises and sets in the west and now I can
say well you're not that short and I
guess you're not I guess you're not that
sure clearly you're not at the Arctic
Circle clearly clearly your your premise
does not work at the Arctic Circle sir
and what's really cool when you're on
the poles okay the Sun rises everywhere
okay so so when you're on the pole the
Sun just slowly begins to appear but
it's always just doing circles around
you that's why and and those circles
it's like a like a helix like a spiral
the circles just kind of rise up oh
that's so cool right right that's right
and then it just goes in Africa and then
it goes below the horizon right but what
it means is they're there months at a
time we have highly sustained Twilight
because there's a point where the Sun is
just its own diameter below the horizon
Tudor and it just stays there as the Sun
goes completely around that's so cool
so that's just I just don't want to put
that one to rest that the Sun rises in
these
and sets in the west it just doesn't and
that's why Manhattanhenge that day of
the year where the Sun rises perfectly
aligned with the street grid of
Manhattan that doesn't happen every day
of the year because the sunrise point is
changing and it doesn't happen on the
equinoxes because the Manhattan grid is
not perfectly aligned east-west gotcha
so it's rotated 29 degrees from the grid
and so you can do the math and you look
it up and you figure it out and that's
what I first did 20 years ago and I
figured out here is the day where the
Sun is gonna set or rise exactly on the
grid and then you have Manhattanhenge
that's super cool well there you have I
love it I love it all right Chuck
another explainer in the can that's
right and now we know so if you ever say
as sure as the Sun rises in the east it
means you're not sure it means you're
not sure all right Jack I had right here
I'm Neil deGrasse Tyson as always
meeting you
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]